[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología y debido a la
emergencia que vivimos a causa de la
pandemia de kobe 19 nos adaptamos desde
nuestros hogares para llevarles toda la
información
-soy valentina torres sánchez gracias
por acompañarme en esta ocasión vamos a
empezar en eeuu mucho se ha hablado de
la efectividad de los diferentes
tapabocas o mascarillas elementos
altamente comunes por esta época pues un
reciente estudio de la universidad
atlántica de florida expone que ni los
tapabocas en el 95 con válvula ni las
pantallas faciales o caretas de plástico
son efectivas para frenar la propagación
del cob y 19 para realizar la
demostración los expertos utilizaron
iluminación con láser y una mezcla de
agua y glicerina con ellos simularon el
vapor y las gotas que se expulsan al
exhalar o toser y se dieron cuenta que
una gran parte de estos fluidos
atraviesan el tapabocas con válvula en
el caso de la careta de plástico lo que
ocurre es que en principio freno a la
expansión para las gotas quedan moviendo
alrededor del visor y luego se desplazan
a otras áreas
con este práctico experimento los
investigadores concluyen que a pesar de
que ambas opciones son cómodas otras
mascarillas serían mucho más eficaces
para frenar la propagación del virus
bajamos un poco en el continente y
llegamos a américa latina porque cada
semana estamos resaltando las
iniciativas que surgen en la región para
controlar la pandemia hoy nos centramos
en perú porque este país es uno de los
más afectados tanto en número de
contagios como de fallecidos y una llama
animal que se remonta al tiempo de los
incas está ayudando a los científicos
peruanos que investigan una probable
cura al virus nuestro corresponsal en
lima francisco zacarías nos cuenta más
de esta investigación
a sus casi seis años tito se ha
convertido en la esperanza de
científicos peruanos quienes estudian un
posible tratamiento contra el cob y 19
empleando una microscópica fracción de
sus defensas que se encuentran en los
linfocitos de su sangre lo que buscamos
en el proyecto es precisamente producir
un anticuerpo específico para esta
proteína el virus para que bloquee la
unión del virus a la célula y evite la
infección evita que el virus ingrese a
la célula y cause la enfermedad los
investigadores introdujeron el
coronavirus a 'tito' para que genere una
respuesta inmune y les permita
desarrollar anticuerpos contra el sars
co2 para luego reproducirlos en
laboratorio los anticuerpos que hayan
sido capaz de neutralizar la infección
en células evaluaremos en hamsters y
también pueden
y disminuir las la infección y los
síntomas que produce esta enfermedad en
este modelo animal el proyecto se
encuentra en una primera fase
y aunque se requerirá probar su
eficiencia los investigadores peruanos
son optimistas en conseguir resultados
favorables él camélido sudamericano ha
sido estudiado en experimentos del vih y
la gripe y su eficacia contra otros
coronavirus como el sars o merz ha sido
aprobado otros modelos animales no
producen estos nano anticuerpos no
entonces esa es la razón por la cual es
diferentes investigadores grupos de
investigación usan camélidos como la
llama alpaca o incluso otros
que no tenemos aquí en el antiguo perú
la llama fue un animal con mucho valor
simbólico y de gran utilidad hoy la
ciencia revaloriza sus cualidades
y potito tito es una de varias llamas
bajo la lupa de científicos de
inglaterra bélgica y eeuu
cambiamos de tema y de continente
llegamos hasta afganistán este país
lleva décadas sumido en enfrentamientos
y violencia por lo que entre otros
productos suele importar los automóviles
que se usan en el interior sin embargo
una compañía local presentó una flota de
novedosos vehículos para pasajeros y
pequeños camiones fabricados localmente
estos autos de los que hay 11 modelos
diferentes
usan la carga de una batería para
funcionar y su costo va desde los 1200
hasta los 2500 dólares
son amigables con el medio ambiente por
las baterías que usan será más económico
para los clientes y también en general
el costo es mucho menor que el de otros
productos que importamos a afganistán
así que confiamos en que el mercado
afgano acogerá este tipo de productos
market
y vamos a finalizar en tokio la capital
japonesa donde fueron instalados unos
curiosos baños en un espacio al aire
libre se trata de cubículos de vidrio
que se mantienen transparentes mientras
la entrada está
desbloqueada pero una vez que las
personas ingresan y ponen el seguro el
vidrio se vuelve opaco o indiscreto
usamos un vidrio especial que es una
capa con una película especial al estar
desbloqueado como ahora hay corriente
eléctrica que lo mantiene transparente
cuando lo bloqueas se frena la corriente
y se vuelve opaco como su diseñador y
con todo muy más n
así llegamos al final de este espacio
cuídense si es posible permanezcan en
casa recuerden que la salud siempre es
lo más importante gracias por su
compañía y continúen con más en france
24 y france24 puntocom
[Música]